in our eye on earth series today is the
50th anniversary of Earth Day we're
marking it in ways we never imagined
because of this global pandemic that
we're all living with right now
satellite images show a dramatic decline
in greenhouse gas emissions thanks to
the drop-off in human activity we're
also seeing wild animals roam in very
unexpected places take a look at that
perhaps the most obvious environmental
change is much cleaner air and that's a
good thing as Jamie yuccas shows us the
big question now for climatologist is
what happens next this is the new normal
for runners in the time of coronavirus
what isn't normal especially here in Los
Angeles
is this blue skies and clean air once
the shelter in place went in in
California what did you see we saw that
LA had some of the cleanest air quality
in the world have you ever seen it this
clear up here before no Lori dolphin
Hammes is CEO of IQ air a tech company
that tracks global air quality two weeks
ago her sensors showed something almost
unimaginable la had the cleanest air of
any major city on earth about a year ago
Los Angeles was ranked the worst air
quality in the entire country and now
we're seeing some of the best air
quality not just in the country but in
the world wide open by some estimates
the pandemic lockdown has taken about
80% of passenger cars off local roads iq
airs data shows a resulting 31 percent
reduction in air pollution compared to
the same time frame last year and it's
not just Los Angeles
from a shockingly smog free New Delhi in
India to unusually clear waters in the
canals of Venice the world is suddenly
learning what can happen if humans stop
polluting the environment but if things
go back to normal a week from now
that'll be a distant memory the air will
be just like it would have been Stanford
environmental scientist Rob Jackson says
there's historic precedent for that
global greenhouse gas emissions dropped
about one and a half percent during the
2008 economic crisis but within two
years they bounced back and kept growing
he fears the same thing could happen
again what if when the economy's hurting
we no longer care or care to safeguard
the environments Senate will come to
order although there are signs that's
already happening in Washington Jackson
is optimistic about the number of people
and companies learning how to
telecommute if we drive less it will
save time and make things healthier it
doesn't have to be shelter at home or
clean air it can be clean air every day
in the meantime while some crucial
climate field science in places like
Greenland is being disrupted the
unprecedented shutdown of major cities
is also proving to be a boon for other
science as well it has allowed us to
really look at certain scenarios that
Gabby Pfister is a climate scientist now
studying our environment in conditions
no one ever thought would occur assume
all passenger cars are taken off the
roads what would happen to our climate
and our air quality I mean this is
typically something we can only test in
our numerical models but then they don't
have observations so now we do armed
with this new data scientists hope when
we do return to our pre pandemic
lifestyles we'll do so with lessons
learned during the crisis it has shown
us that there are ways that we can make
a significant change in the human
footprint on our atmosphere
our of nature for CBS this morning Jamie
yuccas Los Angeles something to think
about there many people see this as a
major reset for Humanity in the planet
I hope we're all listening and get the
lesson